toi
qui es nous nous
ne sommes personne notre mission est de surveiller l'
activité extraterrestre sur terre
Paco tu sais tu n'es pas censé être au
nord de Canal Street qui est knuckle
c'est relax pong tu me cherches
pas trop fou hein deux hommes adultes
parler au mur mur répondre
c'est le bordel mais bon ne t'inquiète même pas
rapport d'incident
accès refusé à qui les choses là-bas tu
n'as pas besoin de savoir ce n'est pas le mensonge que
tu m'as dit quand tu m'as recruté je
te promets les secrets  de l'univers
rien de plus, quels autres secrets
y a-t-il ok
ok je cherche Kay, tu l'as vu un peu
comme un vieux gentleman hargneux, il
sourit comme ça ok il est mort depuis
plus de 40 ans,
prends ça maintenant, tout ce que tu as à faire  c'est
sauter, tu veux que je saute dans le temps,
ok, comment connais-tu mon nom